hi my name is Shabnam O'Hara B and I'm
the CEO of a company called SoulPancake
SoulPancake is a media company we were
founded by Rainn Wilson the actor who
played Dwight Schrute on the office the
u.s. office not the British office I
have to say that because there's always
Brits in the audience and our mission is
to create positive uplifting inspiring
content that we distribute digitally to
about 10 million fans on social have
amassed half a billion video views on
that content and we create content for
television for branded engagements and
ultimately human connection through
storytelling sometimes it's really
thought-provoking sometimes it's very
deep but ultimately it's always about
joy so the story I'm gonna tell today is
about how joy transformed my own
personal life because I believe joy is a
very powerful force and I think
sometimes when you say the word joy
people look at you like you're a
Pollyanna
like you're a little bit naive maybe a
little dumb and and you are oblivious to
the realities of the world how can you
talk about joy and look at the messiness
of life and the messiness of world and
any way shape or form and be taken
seriously but I believe the joy is very
powerful and so my story starts with how
my family perceives me and my family and
friends kind of perceive me as a little
bit more of an e or than a Tigger I
definitely am the person who's like when
a bad grade when I got a bad grade in
high school
it weighed me down I really struggled to
like you know compete with all the other
people in class and I was always like oh
there's so much that I need to do and
achieve and it's so hard and I think
part of that comes from being the first
born child of immigrants I think when
you grow up with immigrant parents part
of your brain carries the struggle that
they brought with you with them and part
of your brain also has this idealism of
changing the world and the opportunity
that lies
ahead of you so that balance of idealism
and cynical reality of the struggle led
me in college to major in the only
possible field journalism so you know
idealism and cynicism it combines really
well for that field
so I study journalism and I worked a
couple of jobs and then I went to grad
school and I went to grad school and
when I was in grad school I wrote a
thesis and I wrote my thesis about the
need for media to create a platform or a
place where Falah philosophical and
spiritual topics could be cool again
I felt like media had kind of sidelined
philosophy and big questions and
thoughtful things to the sidelines and
it just wasn't cool to talk about
philosophy and spiritual topics anymore
so I write this thesis and I put it away
in my parent's garage fast forward seven
years later and I'm living in Washington
DC it's 2008 and I'm working at a
magazine company and I happen to be
running a team that creates content in
the housing industry in real estate home
design development and so on and I
remember vividly one day it was fall
November of 2008 and I'm driving down
Connecticut Avenue in Washington DC the
trees are all sorts of beautiful colors
and I'm driving to work and I hear on
the radio an interview on NPR with this
actor from the office Rainn Wilson and
he's talking about this site that he and
some friends are gonna launch called
SoulPancake and they are going to tackle
life's big questions and they're gonna
make philosophical and spiritual topics
cool again and I thought oh my god Rainn
Wilson stole my idea and I was really
upset now to understand just how upset I
was you kind of have to understand where
I was in my life at this time and
low-point doesn't even begin to describe
it that period of my time that period of
the fall of 2008 entailed a number of
factors going on in my life I was
engaged to be married and I had actually
called off my engagement a few weeks
before hearing range
on the interview so I was very depressed
I was very unhappy I was feeling like
you know my personal life was a bit of a
show in addition to that and let me
tell you guys one of the hardest things
I've ever had to do is call that off and
like call people and say yeah that's not
happening anymore yeah so so that was
happening simultaneous to that again
this is 2008 and I'm working in the
housing industry so simultaneously to
that I had been called in by my boss and
told you basically had to lay I had to
layoff half of my staff and those are
some painful conversations to bring in
people who work hard and you're telling
them that they no longer have their
livelihood those are some rough
conversations simultaneously to that it
was my ten-year high school graduation
you know reunion so I was spending most
of my nights at this point going home
after work lying in bed eating a pint of
Ben and Jerry's chunky monkey sitting on
Facebook looking at all of my high
school classmates and my nemec's and
saying oh look at what they're doing and
look at how awesome their lives are
right now and of course that day I hear
rains interview it just was the bottom
of the low I was like and of course this
celebrity has taken this idea I had and
he's running with it
now at that time that specific day I
went home and I got in bed with my
chunky monkey and and I got a call from
my mom my mom calls me and she's like
hey shabby she's the only person in my
life who calls me shabby hey shabby and
I'm like hi mom and she says how are you
I'm okay I'm good what are you doing as
I'm eating my chunky monkey working I'm
working and and she goes so I'm calling
because I've decided we're going on a
family trip in December and we're gonna
go on a holy pilgrimage the whole family
all together
sidenote I'm a Baha'i that's my religion
and a lot of our holy places and temples
are in Haifa Israel so it's often place
that the highs go so my mom calls me and
says in December we're all going we're
getting on a plane we're all going to
Israel and we're going to do this like
holy tree
together and I'm like huh no I don't
want to do this mom this sounds awful it
sounds like the worst thing that I've
ever heard of and and my mom proceeds to
put on her immigrant guilt at and says
but Shabnam
but Shabnam your dad and I were getting
older you and your sisters you're gonna
get married and have your own family
soon and then you're not gonna want to
do anything with us this is the only
time that we can all go on this trip
together and I'm like when's the dates
mom so I proceeded to go on this trip
in December so I get on this plane and I
go to Israel and my whole family is
dutifully praying and meditating in
these temples and I'm sitting in the
corner arms crossed and decidedly not
praying or meditating or doing anything
but thinking about my life and all that
went through my head is why God why me
how many of you have had that that like
why me moment right so I'm sitting there
stewing and after a couple days of this
thinking about what's going on in my
life my realized that my frustration had
turned into conviction and my anger had
turned into resolve and I came out of
those couple of days of having reflected
and thought about what was going on in
my life and I came out and I decided I
was going to find a way no matter what
to be a part of SoulPancake it felt like
it was my professional soulmate and I
had to be involved so I got back to
Washington DC and I started emailing
Facebook messaging texting calling
carrier pigeon
anyone I could who was in LA who might
be able to put me in touch with Rainn
Wilson and his team so eventually
through so many connections a friend of
a friend of a friend put me in touch
with the guy who was working with rain
on SoulPancake and I get on the phone
with him and I say hey I would love to
help with what you're doing at
SoulPancake and he says oh yeah awesome
what do you do again I said I do content
I'm a journalist I'm working as a
magazine editor I do content I'm a story
and so he said awesome
well we have all these bells and
whistles and all this technology that
we've built we've got a group of people
who are willing to contribute but we
don't really have any content and we
launch soon and I said okay well when do
you launch and he said we launch in
about a month and if you've ever worked
in the content space that is no time at
all
so I basically said well give me some
equity in the company and I will get
your content up and running and I turned
around and spent the next four weeks
calling in favors organizing the
strategy and getting everyone pulled
together writing content being up all
hours of the night because I was still
working a full-time job and getting
SoulPancake launched that was eight
years ago
now I tell this story because and the
reason that it relates to joy is because
the shift that I've seen in my life
since that moment has been a markedly
different approach to life and from
going from that very very bottom low
that I was in where I felt like the
world was against me and nothing was
going right that your mentality I
wouldn't say I've become a full-on
Tigger but I've made a lot of progress
towards it and there are three tools
that I keep going back to again and
again that came came up in that period
of transition for me the first one is I
had nothing to lose so I was super
detached from the outcome I was super
detached brain was gonna make
SoulPancake whether I was involved in it
or not it was gonna happen whether I
reached out or not and I had nothing to
lose and reaching out so I was super
detached from any potential outcome that
was going to come the second tool kit
the tool that I that I was able to take
from that is how powerful gratitude is
that I essentially every time I reached
out to someone and asked them to connect
me to someone to help me get in touch
with Rainn I felt so grateful that they
had taken the time to do it and when the
team at SoulPancake said yeah come on in
help us I felt so grateful for that
opportunity and to this day every
project we work
everything that comes across my desk I
feel so grateful that I get to do
something where I work at a company that
I see is my professional soulmate every
single day and the third thing that I
learned in that process is how important
it is to not compare yourself to other
people I was spending my nights
literally on Facebook stalking ex
classmates like it was a bad period and
it wasn't until I a later that I came
across a quote that's attributed to
Theodore Roosevelt that I realized just
how important that is the quote is
comparison is the thief of joy I love
this quote it's one of my favorite
quotes comparison is the thief of joy
and I realized that in all in all of my
life leading up to that moment I was
always so attached to the outcome but
what if it doesn't turn out exactly the
way I wanted it to or expected it to I
wasn't grateful for the great and
amazing things and people I did have and
I was comparing myself every single day
to what was going on with other people
and so I've since that time taken those
three elements and I've implemented them
in every part of what happens with
SoulPancake last year we were acquired
by participant media which is a film
company here in Los Angeles and the
process leading up to that was super
arduous I had more than 65 meetings with
potential investors and strategic
partners and I was told no over and over
and over and over again but that same
toolkit that got me to SoulPancake in
the first place
got us to the successful exit because I
wasn't attached to the outcome I was so
grateful for every meeting we had even
when they said no because I was able to
tell our story and I didn't compare
ourselves to what every other company
was doing when they would get investment
when they would sell I said that's their
story but I'm not gonna let it deprive
me of mine and so if I can leave you
with anything especially those of you
who are a little bit more ER than you
are Tigger you can find small ways to
bring a little bit more joy into your
life like I did thank you very much
you